so we are taking the idea of
construction we will have the first 3d
printed
town where there will be 27 000
residents after we have the three-year
high school
the four-year university and all the
people that it takes to survive
our own town
[Music]
sharon abbott thank you so much for
being on my show how are you today
wonderful thank you sharon uh you had a
dream
in the year by about 2000 right
to create something big to create
something really magical
and impactful what was that dream i had
been
talking to my brother at christmas in
december of 2000
and we were talking about the fact that
he was adopted by my parents
and how many children in the u.s there's
200 000 children who are living on the
streets without a parent
or an adult to help guide them or
protect them 200
000 200 000 under 18 years old
with not a single adult to take care of
them
and it it broke my heart and so my
brother tony and i decided that we would
do something
which is create a school for kids at
risk to help get kids off the streets
from the united states
and so we were going to do a little
school 350 kids
350 boys because at 15 years old there's
no programs out there for these kids
you know there's programs for
six-year-olds there's programs for
ten-year-olds
you know people will take in a
ten-year-old but not a fifteen-year-old
so we decided we would do something to
help get these kids
they really need a break you know they
really need somebody to champion
them and um so i started you know
the process of let's create something
and
so that became ultimate business
university ubu
and it's just a great acronym for you
know i want kids to learn how to be
themselves
and then my brother passed away in 2008
and before he passed away
i promised him that i would make this
school happen
and because i had so much time i sold
my house my car my jewelry everything
and i went all in on an investment i
have no home
i have no car i have nothing and what i
have is in a 5x10
storage unit and i am 100
invested in making this school happen
for kids
and i am days away it could be tomorrow
it could be
friday but i am days away from having
the investment mature so that i can not
only start a school for 6 000
boys and girls from the united states
that will be
moved to belize so a judge will
interview them
and the judge will say you can go to
juvenile hall because you stole food
because you're hungry
or you broke into a building because you
need to get out of the cold
or you need to get out of the heat or
you can go to police
and have a three-year high school
program and at 15 years old kids can be
emancipated
and they can choose what they want to do
with their life
so we now will have in a three-year time
period
taking 500 boys 500 girls every six
months
move them to belize and we have five
judges across the country
and they will be able to have the most
progressive
education so we'll have trade school
we'll have required curriculum
we will have auto mechanics we will have
agriculture horticulture
we will have animal husbandry we'll have
every practical skill there is
so that these kids will always know that
they can fend for themselves
and we will do things to bring them out
of
imagine living on the streets and having
to survive
and the defenses the kids have to
to develop to survive right so we will
help break down those defenses so they
get a chance to live their life without
having
anger abandonment issues
all the things that come from having to
live on the streets and
be completely responsible for your own
life
one boy i met was 12 years old he comes
home from school his mother moved and
didn't even tell him
where she was going so he has been on
his own
on the street since he was 12 years old
he's now 28
remarkable young man he goes around the
world and he teaches people
how to make farms so that they can be
self-sustaining
creating food for themselves that's
imagine
a young man doing that because he was
homeless and he feels so much for people
who can't take care of themselves
so that's the dream and we are
within days i have 165 people on my team
from 38 countries
we have everything from the agriculture
horticulture
we have people my farm
director is from dublin ireland i have
um my landscape architect is from turkey
i have a shipping uh director who
is from um
i have i mean it is so incredible
i have people like my ceo
tom build the civic center in las vegas
nine billion dollar project and he wants
to
walk away from this corporate
construction world
and come and help bring this project to
life
i have spent four years trying to
connect with people
who are in shanghai who have a company
called winsome and four months ago
my guy from india who is also part of
the farming
he connected with the branch in nigeria
and two days ago i got the final
agreement that we're gonna partner
so we will be able to use 3d printing
to build the school 400 000
square feet six story buildings in one
week inhabitable in four weeks
we can build ten fifteen hundred square
foot homes
a day inhabitable in four weeks
so we are taking the idea of
construction we will have the first
3d printed town where there will be 27
000 residents
after we have the three-year high school
the four-year university
and all the people that it takes to
survive our own
town where we will create this i call it
neo-topia the new utopia the way people
want to live
so you don't have to lock your door you
trust the people that you live next to
that you can walk around it's a town
so you can walk around and feel
perfectly safe your kids are safe
you don't have to worry about somebody
you know taking advantage of you
this is the way the world should be this
is our own
neotopia the way we want the world to be
and it starts in belize and then we will
expand to 24 countries
within 12 to 15 years so
it's a big big project
sharon a lot of people talk about their
dreams and about their aspirations
and goals and you're starting off with
christmas
and i guess more 20 years ago
with a with a dream and i'm very sorry
to hear that your brother passed away
but i i can only imagine the impact that
you're having and you're going to have
on so many thousands of lives not just
the impact by the way that it will
happen
when the project comes to fruition they
actually there but
i i was tearing up here listening to to
your to to the story of how you founded
this and
and how this is going to touch so many
thousands of youth and
you know i think about a lot of the a
lot of you that i see
you know we're talking here about kids
who really have very little
a very uh unfortunate upbringing
in their surroundings yeah they have
nothing
and you what amazes me is you know we
think about the united states
you know the united states has only
three countries that are worse than we
are here in the u.s for kids dying of
malnutrition before
they're two years old i mean that is
unexcusable
i mean we have one in five adults goes
to bed hungry
every single day in this country and i
just did the math
a couple of weeks ago because somebody
made this comment
that the united states is so big that
the whole world population could fit
into the united states
if every person in the world eight and a
half billion people lived in the united
states
every single person would have a quarter
of an acre
and yet what people are homeless people
have no
food people have no education they have
no
power they have no running water
what is excuse for that so we will have
28 divisions that address those issues
all over the world so one of our first
projects
as we're building the school is called
little
syria and we will take a million people
who are in syrian refugee camps
and move them to a brand new land 3d
print
their entire country so
four buildings that are that are four
hundred thousand square feet that's the
infrastructure
we can house a million people in just
two months
then we end up building their homes with
10 printers
we can build 100 homes a day
we will teach them to be self-sustaining
they will never have to worry about
another country or
other people coming in to try to take
over
they will be completely taken care of
but taught
to take care of themselves and
why hasn't this happened before the
oldest refugee camp
is in india 1983
the oldest refugee camp the u.n
has the resources why does that still
exist
and i'm not even going to tell you the
travesties
that go on there because it is
heartbreaking
it is disgusting it is not human to
treat people this way
so when we look at how the world has
changed
and you know thank goodness at your age
you're not aware of some of the things
that have happened in the world
but we are in an age where
there are a lot of us who are now
going to step up and make sure that
these things
never happen again so within five years
no hunger did you know that 100 million
a year
eliminates hunger around the world not
one person would ever go to bed hungry
with a hundred million dollars a year
did you know that the nobel peace prizes
the awards
are paid for through the platform that
was started
after world war ii if somebody put
100 million on a platform and
dedicated that to world hunger there
could be
no hunger anywhere so we will do that
since nobody else is bothered we will do
that
so how many things can be addressed by
somebody just being aware of it
why are people homeless why is it in
california
where you are where i am there are no
institutions since reagan was governor
to take care of people who have mental
disorders
that's where a lot of our homeless come
from because there's no places for them
to live
so what if we create an
environment a camp for these people to
go to feel like they're
outside to feel like they have the
freedom but they have to do things to be
self-sustaining
but to create an environment where they
don't feel threatened
you know and they if you if you go north
to oakland
now i made myself do this because
i see a problem and i put myself in the
center of the problem because when i'm
in the middle of it
i get really creative so i'm walking
around
oakland a year ago in november
and i have to walk around three feet
of trash everywhere all along broadway
which is a
beautiful area when jerry brown was
governor
and when he was mayor of san francisco
he made these
areas really beautiful he took them out
of this
impoverished area and he made them
absolutely gorgeous
well they're just trash now weeds up to
your waist
trash everywhere homeless people i
walked up broadly
and had a homeless guy bump into me and
he yelled at me
because he hit me from his right side
and he's blind in his right eye like i'm
supposed to know this
you know and it's like why isn't
somebody taking care of this man
you know why is he living homeless on
the streets
and why does he feel like he has to be
so
defenseless you know it's
it's inhumane how we treat people we
treat
animals better than we treat a lot of
human beings
if we look at veterans the idea
of somebody going off you've been there
you go
serve the military and you come home and
you have nothing
but maybe you have shell shock maybe you
have ptsd
and there is a um a young man
who played for the oakland raiders and
i worked with him 15 years ago
and he has ptsd and he can't hold the
job
but he also played for the oakland
raiders so
there's a dichotomy there that doesn't
make sense
like why hasn't somebody said okay you
don't
have to be on the edge all the time and
scratching every day for your survival
what else could you do so i came up with
a program
where i said why don't you go out and
interview all the people you played
football with
create an audio program and then go out
and speak
in front of high school students and
then be able to sell this these are the
famous famous football players he didn't
have
the wherewithal to do that so i said
i'll do the interviews
he didn't have the wherewithal to be
able to give me their names
and he is a well-known ex-football
player
you know people are left at the wayside
there's one person who played from the
oakland age at the same
time another person did vita blue
it makes ten thousand dollars every time
he speaks publicly
the other person he worked with mike who
was on the
oakland a's at the same time he's on
disability he had eight back surgeries
because of baseball
he has nothing why is there such
a disparity in the way they live their
lives
sharon i have to say that you know from
what we're talking about here
first of all i i completely agree these
are um
awful issues that and i'm very inspired
by the way that you're approaching them
and you're not just thinking you're not
just saying there are issues but you're
also
putting yourself in the center of them
and thinking creatively how to address
them
one of the things that i'm taking my for
myself as an entrepreneur and on my
journey
you know talking about back to the
school that that you're creating and
talking about the syrian refugees a
million refugees and
and building a sustainable a community
to for them to live in a matter of weeks
or months it's unbelievable
and it's a lot of it is because of
technology and because of innovation
this
idea that you can 3d print a community
or a school
i mean that's exactly why i came to the
bay area after my service and that is
exactly what i
why i started this show it's to gain
perspective on what are the different
ways
that us technologists can leverage deep
technology
and and and you know interesting
to impact the lives of people for the
better and a lot of people can say
one way to do that is through better
digital transformations on our own
computer screens another way could be to
actually go and build
cities and build schools and sharing
what you're talking about here is
is literally saving lives and and i'm
getting so much inspiration from these
stories
sharon you know i i obviously the things
that you're doing
now are are incredible and they're
they're completely inspiring
you have an incredible background of
working with tech companies in tech you
mentioned that you've also
lectured at stanford quite a few times
you were an oprah winfrey
talking about talking about your
projects so
so talk to me a little bit about it
where you came from what what excited
you throughout your career
we don't have much time left but i'd
love to hear a little bit about who
sharon abbott is
so i grew up in a very small town there
were 10 000 people in 10 square miles
and we grew the food that we ate and we
traded for what we didn't grow
and you never locked a door everybody
knew who you were everybody watched out
for each other
and to me that's the way the world
should be
it was hard for me to adjust to being in
a world that wasn't like that
and so i'm looking to bring my world
my sphere of influence back to that
where
you know people are happy every day
doing what they love to do and not doing
the job just because they have to
survive
you know when i grew up one person in
the family worked
and everybody was able to survive and do
well
today two people in the family have to
work and the children never see their
parents
so in the united states children under
12 under 12 years old
65 percent never see their parents other
than on the weekends
to me that's wrong we should not put
people in that position
so how how do i take the things that i
loved about growing up
in the middle of mendocino in the town
of mendocino three and a half miles
inland
with 80 acres of state forest
surrounding me
to the point where we were free we had
fun we knew what fun was basic
fun and today kids don't know so much
about that because they're glued to a
computer screen
they're playing games all the time you
know
i look around and i think what are
people missing out on
what inspired me i was very fortunate
i had dyslexia i stuttered
i had teachers that pulled me aside and
said if you do this
then this will be the result my
sophomore year
in high school i said i need to go to
college and each one of my teachers said
here's your assignment and i graduated
with a 3.8
when my sophomore year i started out
with a 2.0
the teachers made the difference and
because i have always seemed to attract
people to come into my life to inspire
me to help me
to guide me i've had amazing mentors in
my life
i have people that have opened up doors
i have managed to be
on a sales team for a fortune 500
company i've had my own companies i
taught entrepreneur skills
for 20 years only because the chamber of
commerce in walnut creek
asked me to run a group and because
people didn't like what was happening at
the chamber
they asked me to run a group outside and
then for 20 years that became a passion
of mine
to help people find out what is the
right path for anybody
who has a passion in their business how
do you do it more effectively more
profitably
more easily so you can spend time with
your family and not spend all your time
working
to me that's what's important i used to
tell people
and i don't even know where this came
from but i didn't create it
you're born and then you die
and your life is the dash between those
years
what does the dash stand for so
i was born in 1950 i'm
70 years old i have lived
an amazing life i have accomplished
amazing things
i have 10 books published i have my
pilot's license
i used to autocross race cars i have
down
skill ski downhill ski race won first
place medals downhill skiing
i have conquered all the things that to
me
they were important you know they were i
today
i can still press 175 pounds
with my legs at 70 years old in november
i mean i have such a strength because
i never saw obstacles i saw a challenge
that i could overcome so
to me every challenge has a solution
and when people acknowledge that yes
there's
challenges in life but that saying about
it's not how many times you fall down
it's how many times you get up that's
been my life
i have managed to overcome things
that most people can't even imagine
i had five times in 12 years
medical doctors told me i would not live
six months
the last time was in 2012
when i i went through breast cancer
kidney failure liver failure all because
of a doctor's mistake
i'm here you know i'm here to inspire
other people
i'm here to make sure that people
realize
the world they live in is the world they
create
so we are not subject to anyone
else's beliefs unless we choose to be
so whatever you want to conquer in your
life
it is possible think about the first
person who ran a four-minute mile
prior to that it wasn't possible now
how many people have run the four-minute
mile so how many things could people
accomplish
if they only realized if somebody else
has done it you can too
maybe if nobody's done it you can
how many times did it take for the first
space shuttle to reach the moon
they had to alter the course 1025 times
with the brilliance of all those
scientists
at nasa guiding that spaceship
so who are we to argue with whatever you
want to do you can accomplish
no matter what it is in the world there
are no impossibilities
there's limitations that we put on
ourselves
and that's what i want the school to be
is
a shining example that these kids who
have been discarded thrown away
living on the streets by themselves have
a chance to live their life in such a
way
that they can accomplish anything they
choose
and your people like you you're able to
go to stanford
you know how fortunate you are there is
no limit to what you can accomplish
you know you think about um tesla's
technology
there are going to be so many releases
of tesla's technology
we're going to see so many things become
available
that most of us think it's just star
trek technology right
no things are real things that we're
going to see coming out in the next few
years
we are going to be amazed at what's
happening
so stay in touch you know do your own
research
don't believe what somebody else tells
you don't believe what i say just
because i say it
but go out and take that responsibility
for yourself
don't listen to mainstream media and
think that that's the only opinion there
is
you know don't read a book and think
that that is the last word
because you have to make up your mind
you know the beauty of living this life
is that we all get to choose
how we live it where we live it what we
do
and you cannot go back at 70 years old
and redo what you did at 25
so every year counts and i am a living
example
of embracing every single challenge
i've ever had and hitting it head on
and realizing that no matter how
difficult the challenge is
there is a way to get through that
and be able to make a difference in this
world
and i think that's what all of us strive
for you know michael
it isn't what we do
behind closed doors it's what we do to
influence people
like a good word
a helping hand i try still every single
day
to have one thing is a good work that i
do
whether it's opening the door for an old
man that would never expect a woman to
open the door
or helping somebody with their packages
or it doesn't matter how little it is
but to inspire somebody by you know
complimenting them
or making them laugh we can make the
world a better place
one person at a time one day at a time
and that's what this is all about
jill that is just inspiring and i am
so thankful for for the fact that you're
so generous with your time so thank you
very very much before we
end and i'm very very sad that we have
to end but before we
have to end i need three words that you
would use to describe yourself
innovative determined
and creative
jill thank you very very much and this
was just wonderful stay safe and stay
healthy and i cannot wait to share this
with the world
i can't wait to come visit the school
myself and all the different communities
that you were talking about
and i can't wait to continue following
your journey
wonderful michael thank you so much
bye-bye
you